[Applaus]
ist das geil
[Musik]
das ganze Klima ist irgendwie jetzt so
vergiftet
und ich frag mich wie das jetzt
weitergehen soll es zeigt sich auch was
es bringt Brandmauern aufzubauen die
Grünen anzustreichen was machen die
Bürger gerade hier in Thüringen Sachsen
in Ostdeutschland im Mitteldeutschland
die stellen einen Ausreise Antrag zu AFD
und das ist hier heute
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist eine reine Parteien
ist es wirklich die unsägliche Politik
der Bundesregierung vielen Dank
[Musik]
ganz im Süden Thüringens im kleinsten
Landkreis des Freistaates regiert bald
Robert Sesselmann Deutschlands erster
AFD Landrat in der Stichwahl ums
kommunale Spitzenamt gewann er gegen
seinen Kontrahenten von der CDU
die Bürger von Sonneberg haben gewählt
und wenn es jetzt der Herr Sesselmann
als neue Landrat ist sollte man das
akzeptieren ich bin einfach nur froh
dass man eine von der AFD an der Macht
ist
ja es ist mir eigentlich nur ich finde
halt ja die wir haben hier ganz viele
Schilder zum Beispiel und das ist halt
einfach ansprechend also mich spricht es
an ich bin den Handwerk tätig und das
ist genau das was ich eigentlich hören
möchte und was mich interessiert und der
andere Bullshit hat mich halt nicht so
wirklich interessiert genau
rechts Partei kann man nicht wählen er
hat ja sich eigentlich zur
Kommunalpolitik gar nicht geäußert und
wird aber trotzdem hier gewählt und
sicher permanent eigentlich so Bundes-
das kann man ja hier eh nicht wählen das
kann doch gar keiner hier beeinflussen
mir bezahlen für die Ukraine es kommen
die Ausländer bezahlen und alles und für
unsere Leute ist kein Geld da
Treff zur Feierabend Runde vom
Sonneberger Rathaus
auch bei Lukas und seiner Truppe ist die
anstehende Stichwahl Thema in die
Politik haben sie nur noch wenig
Vertrauen angesichts der vielen Krisen
erst Corona jetzt krieg was sie dazu
denken würde keinen interessieren
und hat halt auch niemand gefragt ob man
jetzt drei Jahre lang zu Hause sitzen
wollen oder ob wir Militärausrüstung
nach Ukraine schicken wollen die ganzen
Themen die machen einen schon ab und zu
mal Angst weil du hast ja trotzdem
manchmal das Gefühl ja was machst du
wenn es jetzt wirklich ausbrechen sollte
alles
tiefer gelegt und auch ein bisschen
wütend sind sie unterwegs in
Südthüringen die jungen Männer arbeiten
im Handwerk und fahren gerne ihre
Verbrenner aus
sie nennen sich sonst City wollen auf
Youtube groß rauskommen mit ihren Autos
und Motors
irgendwo muss man ja stolz sein auf das
was man machen
dass die AFD hier den ersten Landrat
stellen könnte regt sie nicht weiter auf
aber wie über die Wähler der Partei
pauschal gesprochen werde
AFD wieder als rechtsextrem oder
Zeichnen ich finde das ist
meiner Meinung nach eigentlich gar nicht
verkehrt wenn man einfach
ein bisschen stolz drauf ist deutsch zu
sein und die deutschen Werte auch
bisschen wart
und deswegen finde ich falsch da alles
so über ein Haufen zu kehren
das Ergebnis des ersten Wahlgangs die
AFD und Sesselmann schon fast am Ziel
er muss also kämpfen CDU Mann Jürgen
Köpper führt seit mehreren Jahren die
Geschäfte im Landratsamt bei der
eigentliche Amtsinhaber krank wurde die
Wahl deshalb jetzt ein Jahr vorgezogen
Körper braucht jede Stimme doch die
frühere Schulkameradin wohnt längst in
bayerischen Nachbarlandkreis
hier bei uns
[Musik]
man kennt sich aber es nutzt diesmal
nichts
das Hauptproblem ich habe die Sachen
alle Körper du bist der feine Kerl wir
würden Dich ja wählen aber wir müssen
eine Veränderung bewerben ne und und
daraus der Landkreise Landratswahl der
völlig falsch oder dazu
war auch Niklas Köhler kämpft für die
CDU vier Tage liegt der erste Wahlgang
zurück und manche Sonneberger wissen
davon gar nichts
47% bekommen gerne auch mal mit Freunden
Bekannten drüber sprechen das haben
viele Leute aus meiner Sicht auch
zurecht den Eindruck dass die Berliner
also die Bundespolitik und wenn man noch
höher geht die Europapolitik dass die er
von dem westdeutschen geprägt ist von
Westdeutschen Politikern von
Westdeutschen Themen die Themen des
Ostens werden dort nicht so behandelt
und ostdeutsche haben dort sicherlich
auch keinen guten Stand dabei ist gerade
hier an der Grenze zu Bayern viel
zusammengewachsen man gehört zur
Metropolregion Nürnberg so gut wie jeder
hat einen Job aber oft nicht gut bezahlt
das Lohnniveau unter Thüringen Schnitt
und weit entfernt vom westmaßstab hier
merken Sie schneller und deutlicher wenn
das Leben teurer wird
Corona Inflation Heizung auch hier beim
Beachvolleyball in Sonneberg werden die
Krisen diskutiert vereins-chef Christian
küco spürt die Stimmung
jetzt ist natürlich die Situation
angespannt durch verschiedene Faktoren
und dementsprechend kämpft ihr
vielleicht auch ein Stück weit unter dem
Wohlstand der hat Angst was zu verlieren
verständlich auch in der ein oder
anderen Stelle
ich weiß nicht ob dann nur meckern der
richtige Weg ist sondern versuchen im
Raum seine Möglichkeiten irgendwie
anzupacken sie tun das engagieren sich
für ihren Verein versuchen etwas voran
zu bringen viele andere aber hätten sich
zurückgezogen in digitale Parallelwelten
keine bezahlt mehr für für Nachrichten
das ist nicht so wie früher das muss ich
Abteilung gekauft hat also geht es darum
wer die beste Überschrift hat und die
wird geklickt wir uns jetzt in der
Vergangenheit auch eine Lokalpolitik wo
wir mit großen Überschriften geworfen
worden sind Corona war ganz großes Thema
schnelle Nachrichten Verbreitung die
nicht gestimmt hat über soziale Medien
und ähnliches das rührt die Bevölkerung
schon mal auf
und die AFD beherrscht dieses Geschäft
Facebook WhatsApp tiktok Wahlbetrug wird
hier angedeutet digital sickert die
Parteien alle Köpfe kaum einer im
Landkreis der ihre Posts nicht kennt
oder von ihnen gehört hat aber tiktok
bei tiktok genau genau da folge ich auch
auf die
und die Stimmungsmache unter anderem
gegen Flüchtlinge trifft hier auf ein
Lebensgefühl der Ausländeranteil in den
letzten Jahren stark gestiegen auf rund
9 % viele beugen das kritisch
wir sind in Deutschland und wir möchten
ein erster Stelle stehen so möchte ich
das jetzt so behalten
gewinnt
rechtsradikal bin oder sonst irgendwas
aber es ist doch ein klares Zeichen
vielleicht auch mal nach Berlin das ist
so nicht weitergehen ne
dass die Parteien Thüringen vom
Verfassungsschutz als erwiesen
rechtsextrem eingestuft wird scheint für
viele hier unwichtig doch genau deshalb
interessieren sich jetzt immer mehr
Medien für Sonneberg
[Musik]
gern würde man auch mal von Robert
Sesselmann etwas hören zu seinem
Wahlkampf seinen Themen doch der
afd-kandidat spricht nicht mit dem ZDF
zu vereinbarten bildterminen kommt nur
der plakatwagen mit dem er seit Tagen
durch den Landkreis tourt
[Musik]
die AFD gibt sich Sieges gewiss einer
der stellvertretenden Bundesvorsitzenden
macht mit beim Wahlkampf
wir werden uns sehr freuen und den
Menschen draußen zeigen was was geht und
das nicht geht
die kameradichte steigt unterdessen auch
bekannte Rechte Blogger streamen nun aus
Sonneberg wir versuchen wieder den
afd-kandidaten beim Wahlkampf zu zeigen
Robert Sesselmann fährt kurzem Cabrio
vor und dreht wieder ab
die CDU mobilisiert noch mal alle Kräfte
in der letzten 14.000 ungefähr 9000
Flyer ausgegeben ne
kugelschreibe waren es ich denke um die
3000 für den haustürwahlkampfreisen
Helfer aus ganz Thüringen an
die Hoffnung mehr Wahlbeteiligung auch
die anderen Parteien hatten dafür
geworben unterstützen so Körper der ist
im ganzen Landkreis unterwegs ich denke
dass wir in der letzten Tagen
sehr gut erreicht haben dass man gute
Gespräche geführt haben und dass ich
denke dass man das eine oder andere
definitiv noch auf die Reihe kriegen bis
morgen
aber ob Sie sich überzeugen lassen
in Steinach hat Ulrich kurz da Zweifel
seit 2006 ist der parteilose hier
Bürgermeister es ist der Ort aus dem
Robert Sesselmann kommt 53% für die AFD
im ersten Wahlgang aller anderen hätten
sie enttäuscht sagen viele hier vorne
Vorsprung
in Deutschland
die leben doch in ihre eigene Blase die
Wissen normale volksampelung wissen
überhaupt nicht
aber wenig machen schon seit langem
fragt sich Ulrich kurz warum das hier so
ist warum Demokratie einfach nicht mehr
interessiert
warum
ich finde das so sinnlos ist doch egal
für mich ist es egal
mittlerweile sind rund 30 Prozent der
Menschen im Rentenalter man blicke
zurück früher war alles vermeintlich
besser und Parteien seien hier gar nicht
mehr verankert
also in Stein noch selbst gibt es
eigentlich keine großartigen Aktivitäten
von Ortsgruppen der Parteien mehr wir
haben so eine parteiunabhängige
Wählergruppe die aus der hervorgegangen
bin als Bürgermeister die aber auch in
ihren Aktivitäten die anfänglich gut
waren steigt nachgelassen hat war eben
die Akteure
älter geworden sind
ausgeschieden sind und so passiert wenig
Engagement im Jahr sterben hier etwa 90
Einwohner nur 25 werden geboren der
Region werden in Zukunft noch mehr
Fachkräfte fehlen ein AFD Mann an der
Spitze des Landkreises ein braunes Image
das hätte Folgen für die Wirtschaft sagt
Axel Müller er ist tourismusunternehmer
betreibt unter anderem die Sportarena
Silbersattel in Steinach
für die Industrie überlegt sich schon
der eine oder andere Unternehmer gegen
eine Region wo meine Mitarbeiter
vielleicht eher gedankenguthaben was
nicht zu meiner Unternehmensphilosophie
passen das ist eher so meine
Befürchtungen
[Musik]
Wahlabend im Sonneberger
Gesellschaftshaus werden die Ergebnisse
der stimmeauszählung präsentiert der
örtliche Sprecher der AFD streamt den
gesamten Abend direkt zur Wahlparty der
Partei
[Applaus]
der Landkreis Sonneberg schreibt
Geschichte die AFD ist nunmehr als
Volkspartei hier im Kommunalbereich in
Thüringen und auch in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland angekommen ich weiß gar
nicht wie ja wie viel er bewegen kann
weil er kann heizungsgesetz nicht
verändern kann die Flüchtlingszahlen
nicht verändern also an welche Stelle er
ansetzt um was zu bewegen das muss er
sich wahrscheinlich noch überlegen was
die Leute interessiert und nicht die
Welt retten
die AFD feiert ihren ersten kommunalen
Amtssitz ganz gut mit blauen Blumen und
Partei vorstellt
bei den anderen Parteien Ernüchterung
zum ersten Mal hat die Strategie alle
gegen die AFD nicht funktioniert jetzt
die Frage wieder mit umgehen in
Thüringen wir erkennen das Ergebnis an
es ist sehr schmerzhaft und danken allen
unseren Wählern die ganz hart und ganz
intensiv an unserer Seite standen und
für uns gekämpft haben herzlichen Dank
dafür
soweit ich würde es schon nicht nur als
Ausrufezeichen bezeichnen sondern als
Dammbruch zum ersten Mal wurde ein
Mitglied einer rechtsextremen Partei in
einen exekutives Amt gewählt und das
muss uns eine Alarmzeichen sein ich
glaube wir müssen den Geist der
deutschen Einheit neu definieren dass
wir die Ostdeutschen mitnehmen und nicht
das Gefühl auslösen dass über sie
gelacht wird oder über sie nur geredet
wird dann werden solche Signale
entstehen
CDU mein Körper Willen Sonneberg
Beigeordneter bleiben Sesselmann wäre
damit sein Chef die AFD in Umfragen ist
sie derzeit die stärkste Kraft in
Thüringen gut ein Jahr vor der
Landtagswahl